[Music]
on this monday night an update on
pandemic spending
the federal fiscal plan unveiled
billions being spent
to help parents businesses and long-term
care homes
we will do whatever it takes to help
canadians how do the numbers add up
i speak with finance minister christian
freeland rising covid19 cases plus
increased restrictions equals declining
mental health
we're getting angry the toll of pandemic
stress
plus difficulty striking a balance no
recovery without a chic covering how
working mothers are now shouldering
even bigger burdens and mammoth
undertaking
how cher helped the world's loneliest
elephants
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with money what it's
going to take to keep canadian families
and businesses afloat through the months
ahead
the federal finance minister christia
freeland who took over the job in august
has laid out how much will be spent to
shore up the economy until this pandemic
is over
before covet 19 canada's deficit for
2020 was projected to be about 34
billion dollars
by july the government predicted it
would balloon 10 times that to 343
billion
well now freeland says it's likely to
jump to 381 billion dollars
because 25 billion is being spent on new
programs
programs the finance minister says will
set the stage for canada's recovery
the wage subsidy is being increased
parents of young children will get more
through the canada child
benefit there's help for airlines and
tourism and
money going to the provinces to spend on
improving long-term care
the finance minister says the risks of
providing too much support outweigh the
risks of not spending
enough david akin breaks it down in our
top story
tonight canadians should know
that their federal government will be
there to help them get through it
come what me and to do that ottawa will
rack up
monster deficits most of that red ink is
a result of covet 19 related support
programs
already in place we will do whatever it
takes
to help canadians stay healthy
safe and solvent
we will invest in every necessary public
health measure
and we will support canadian families
and canadian businesses
in a deliberate prudent and
effective way but christopher freeland
will add to it
with some new items for example there
will be a temporary boost to the canada
child benefit
of up to twelve hundred dollars per
child under the age of six
this will be a means-tested benefit and
available only for
low and middle-income families ottawa
will set up a new
lending program for tourist businesses
airlines hotels and
other firms hard hit by the pandemic
loans of up to
one million dollars on a 10-year term at
ultra-low rates will be available
all one hundred percent backed by the
government the provinces will split an
extra one billion dollars
which they can use to improve long-term
care facilities
and those crucial business support
programs like the emergency rent subsidy
and the emergency wage subsidy
well they've been locked in until june
on top of that
the government has boosted the wage
subsidy to 75 percent
from 60 percent and that rate has been
locked in
at least until the middle of march
freeland's fiscal statement
also lays some markers for future
spending on
pharmacare and child care but does not
commit to major spending now
on either of those files but freeland
does say that
starting next year the government will
put aside between
70 to 100 billion dollars a year for
three years in a row
on economic recovery projects details of
that spending will be announced later
and we conceivably add to future
deficits
and so now donald the political debate
begins and it really hinges on this
question
can we afford all this spending can we
afford all these deficits
and quite clearly the government says
yes and you can expect that christopher
freeland and her cabinet colleagues
will now move up the move about the
country with this message
that canada can't afford not to spend
this money
to get us to the other side of the
pandemic donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks the
leader of the official opposition aaron
o'toole accused the government of
lacking a firm plan on vaccines and on
managing the economy
do we have the freezers for the minus 70
vaccine mr speaker a robust portfolio in
2023
doesn't help us as we enter 2020
well mr speaker this fall economic
statement
answers the question on whether there is
a plan
and it answers that no there is not
and the finance minister christie
freeland joins me now ms freeland thank
you so much for taking time with us
today
you took over this job in the middle of
a pandemic nothing is certain now
you don't know where the bottom is or
how bad things will get
is this a case of planning for the worst
and hoping for the best
always absolutely and that's it's
actually a great point and a great
question donna
what we've tried to do in our fiscal
projections
for the nerds among your viewers
is offer a couple of scenarios including
very much
a worst case scenario and we've built
all of our projections
on that worst case scenario because i
think that that's the prudent thing to
do
prepare for the worst hope for the best
this is a startling amount of money to
spend
how can you reassure canadians that it
is enough to stabilize the economy and
also why didn't you include a fiscal
anchor put a limit or a cap on how much
you'll spend
um so let me it is a lot of money
and i want to start by assuring
canadians
that i take that very very seriously
i think the first thing that should be
reassuring to all of us
is that our debt servicing charges are
imminently manageable they are actually
the lowest they have been
in a hundred years and we are working
very hard right now to push out the
maturities
on our debt to lock in today's low
interest rates so
that would be point one um to your
second question
of will this be enough
it goes back to your first one that we
have really built
several layers of projections and we
have
built our growth plan on the basis
of the most pessimistic projections
so yes i really believe that
this will be enough our plan is working
so far
we've recovered 80 of the jobs lost
at the bottom of the crisis and i am
really confident that we're going to be
able to come roaring back
and what about the fiscal anchor putting
a limit or a cap on how much
you're prepared to spend um excellent
question
and we did something very meaningful in
that direction today
which is we are going to bring in
something that i am calling fiscal guard
rails
to guide our stimulus spending so
there is a really meaningful question
that canadians should ask themselves
that i will be asking myself
when it comes to the growth plan and
that is when do you know you're finished
when do you know you've done enough the
fiscal guardrails will do that and they
are
very focused on jobs so we're going to
look at
the rate of employment the rate of
unemployment and hours worked in the
economy
and that's going to let us know how much
we need to put into our growth plan and
when it's finished and that's why we
offered a range today we said between
three and four percent of gdp 70
to 100 billion dollars and we did also
say you know the question
of fiscal anchors is an important one
and we said today that as the economy
gets back to normal we will bring in
fiscal anchors
as well i know you don't have a crystal
ball
of course but when do you think
canadians can begin to breathe easy
again it won't be the moment a
successful vaccine is approved but
i don't know maybe in three to six
months from then
um you know donna i don't have
a crystal ball but what i can say today
which i think would have been more
difficult for us all to say a couple of
months ago
is we know for sure this pandemic is
going to end
we know for sure there are now at least
three vaccines
that have shown very good results
and canada has an extensive portfolio
of vaccines the strongest portfolio of
vaccines
in the world so what we can say for sure
is yeah
it is going to be a hard winter and i
think we need to kind of
mentally fasten our seat belts for
a difficult couple of months but the
vaccines
are coming we know the pandemic
will end and we also know that thanks to
really the historic support the federal
government has provided
individual canadians and canadian
businesses
are in pretty good shape going into
that growth plan and we're going to
provide them with
a little more fuel to have real takeoff
all right deputy prime minister and
finance minister christiaa freeland
in ottawa thanks and all the best to
your family
okay you too donna very nice to talk to
you
mercedes stevenson is with me now from
ottawa mercedes not too many people envy
christian freeland right now managing
the country's finances in a pandemic
requires going into uncharted territory
what stood out to you in this fiscal
update
well donna what stood out to me is that
it looked more like a budget than a
fiscal update
it was over 270 pages and very detailed
on the now
it was really that focus on managing
from day to day and that is what a lot
of canadians wanted to hear they're
relying on programs they've already
established
that they believe they have evidence are
working well to serve businesses and
canadians
they're going to refine those programs
but this is not the time for them to
float the big ideas
or put a lot of money into programs that
they are unsure of
so you're certainly seeing them focusing
in on that day-to-day
uh really how to get canadians through
the pandemic
and then worry about what's on the other
side later it's a tough thing for the
conservatives to attack
and it gives them lots of room to
negotiate with the ndp to stay in power
well the liberals got elected on
promises of national child care a
national child care program a national
pharmacare program
are those ideas on ice now
well they're still in this document but
there's basically no details and no
money really allocated to them and these
are two very expensive programs
not because they're not looking at them
donna but because i believe they are
saving their political firepower
for the spring this is what you can
expect to see in the spring budget
and if the opposition then tries to
bring the government down over these
issues
i've certainly talked to a lot of senior
liberals who are more than willing
to fight an election on them all right
election talk again we're stating
stevenson in ottawa thanks
never ends
key to the government's recovery plan is
the availability of a safe and effective
vaccine
none has been approved yet but today
there is a bit more reason for optimism
biotech company moderna now says the
final trial results have confirmed its
vaccine is
94 percent effective it's now applying
to the us
and the european union for emergency
approval
our best guess is that this will proceed
through the first couple weeks of
december
and maybe by the middle or end of
december we would hopefully have
an emergency use authorization
health canada said last week it's
working on the same timelines for
approval as the u.s
and the eu in addition to moderna canada
is also reviewing vaccine candidates
from pfizer astrazeneca and
johnson johnson the federal government
has pre-ordered millions of doses from
all those companies and
canada's minister of intergovernmental
affairs says the first doses could
arrive as early
as january as we wait for a vaccine our
best defense against the virus is
continuing to limit who we come into
contact with
because the virus is still spreading
fast alberta is the worst right now more
than 1700
new cases were reported there today and
eight more albertans died
more than 450 people are hospitalized
with covet and almost 100 are in
intensive care
and alberta's chief medical officer says
the numbers are nowhere near
the peak here is the map showing active
case numbers in canada alberta has the
most
active infections followed by ontario
quebec and then manitoba
when you break it down by population
manitoba remains the hardest hit region
per capita
as of last night it had 670 active cases
per 100 000 people
and over the last 24 hours in manitoba
more than 340 more people tested
positive
there are now a record 342 coven 19
patients in the hospital there
that's more than triple the number of
hospitalizations just one month ago
in the last month 247 people in manitoba
have died of cobit 19
and that occlu includes a child who is
under the age of 10.
a child died over the weekend it's been
18 days since the entire province of
manitoba
was placed under code red restrictions
manitoba's top doctor says he
understands people are getting tired
but says they have to stick with it or
cases and deaths will keep climbing
although these restrictions are very
difficult
and it's been a long haul we need these
in place right now
and so we ask all manitobans to follow
them not look ways
to get around them and for the most part
to stay home
a small minority of canadians don't
believe the rules apply to them and
others are just tired of living by them
mike derle has more on the frustrations
building
as the pandemic drags on
it's hard to compete with the gusty
winds of a snowstorm in rural manitoba
harder still with rcmp officers blocking
the highway
let the people go to church the standoff
between religious rights and public
health
ended with the minister delivering his
sermon on the back of a pickup truck
so there's no government there that can
prohibit us from worshiping god
with the highest per capita covet 19
rates in the country
the manitoba government ordered among
other restrictions that religious
services go virtual
a similar order to one in bc that has
resulted in church leaders being
fined nationally canada's health
relative to covet 19
has never been worse the number of
active cases in the country has doubled
in the last
month and with that has come a slew of
regionally unique public policies
that have left many people confused and
confounded
this is really where the rubber hits the
road in terms of the tension between
individuals and the public's interest
and and i think
it's a very challenging area in
any democracy the rain kept protesters
away from this toronto area barbecue
restaurant today
but it's been at the epicenter of a
boisterous debate over how public policy
is meted out
while businesses in two gta regions
aren't allowed to have customers enter
their stores due to a lockdown
just a few streets over a mall is
thriving with massive lineups
how are canadians dealing with all of it
professor of psychiatry roger mcintyre
says
it's the unpredictable element of
chronic stress
that worries him the most we've got
pervasive mistrust in almost every
sector in every structure of our society
what does this do it really coarsens us
and it coarsens us in the sense that we
in fact
are acting out we're getting angry and
you're seeing some of this being act out
the only solution he believes is getting
the vaccine into the hands of canadians
and putting the pandemic behind us
microlight global news toronto
british columbia is reporting another
major spike in cases and deaths
over the last three days more than 2300
people in bc have tested positive and
46 more people have died that is the
biggest jump in deaths
since the start of the pandemic
these people have faces have names have
stories
have families if you are thinking that
it may be okay
to bend the rules please remember that
this virus
takes lives
in bc a record 316 people are in the
hospital with covid 1975 of them in
intensive care a frightening moment
on a snowy highway coming up a
heart-stopping collision
caught on video
this terrifying moment was caught on a
dash cam along a snow-covered highway
in bc that snowplow crossed into
oncoming traffic and hit a truck it's
believed the plow's blade may have
caught on some ice
causing it to swerve the truck driver
was injured but not seriously
the weather network is forecasting a
winter of extremes in most of canada
this year because
the la nina effect in the south pacific
will create a strong jet stream
separating warm southern air masses from
their colder northern counterparts
newfoundland and labrador is the only
province expected to have a typical
winter so good for them
the rest of us prepare for some snowy
icy roads
in the months ahead f1 driver romay
grosjean spoke from his
hospital bed today about sunday's
terrifying crash that could have killed
him
i am okay well sorry okay
thank you very much for all the messages
it happened on the opening lap of
bahrain's grand prix grosjean's car
appeared to pierce the barrier split
in half and then burst into flames he
managed to walk away
he has burns to his hands and knows how
lucky he is
today he thanked the racing federation
for its massive strides to keep drivers
safe
he believes something called the halo
kept him alive a curved titanium bar
that protects the heads of drivers
and was made mandatory in 2018
ahead the pandemic's imbalance and
instability on women juggling family
and finances
in alberta students in grades 7 to 12
return to remote learning today and that
tends to add to the stress of women who
have to try to balance their jobs with
having kids at home
heather urix west herself a mother of
young children explains
tina ferguson is a mother of four before
the pandemic she'd care for her two
preschool-aged kids during the day while
her older two were at
school heading to work at a dinner
theater in the evening when her husband
was home
it was an arrangement that worked until
covet 19.
we were off for six months and then
called back in september laid off again
in
november this year just a few days ago
her husband's hours have also been
reduced and as of this week in alberta
her older kids are back to doing school
at home
serb and now e.i are helping but this
family admits
they are just getting by we're just
skating by with what we get
which we're so thankful for don't get me
wrong we're very thankful for
what we do get but we're just skating by
we have all been trying to
save our businesses and still have to be
at home
parenting and homeschooling tennis
deerlin's travel business has been
devastated by the pandemic
and outside of the serb she hasn't
qualified for any government program
so far the newly created credit program
for highly affected sectors could help
but it doesn't help with that other
full-time job right now caring for kids
that are now in school online from home
we're getting further away from recovery
recover
the recession is getting longer and
deeper
because we are not doing anything fast
enough
about the one policy amenable lever
we have to hasten recovery which is
early learning and child care and for
women like ferguson that burden comes
with plenty of anxiety about what's to
come
knowing that this pandemic is likely
several months from being over
heather urex west global news calgary
next the world's loneliest elephant now
in good company
thanks to the goddess of pop
there's some good news tonight about
cavan known as the world's loneliest
elephant he's landed at his new home a
wildlife sanctuary in cambodia
the singer cher was there she led the
campaign to rescue the 36 year old
elephant from pakistan where he was
isolated mistreated and
had become dangerously overweight his
partner died in 2012.
well now he's in the cambodia wildlife
sanctuary where staff say he got a juicy
fruit cake
as a welcome and has some female
neighbors to keep him company
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is near kersley bc thanks for
watching
[Music]
bye